>> Tucker: TONY FAUCI IS NOW A
FIGURE OF RELIGIOUS VENERATION
FOR THE KIND OF AMERICANS WHO
THINK STARBUCKS MAKES GOOD
COFFEE.
SO IT MAKES SENSE AS A GOD
STARTING THE EARTH THAT
TONY FAUCI HAS HIS VERY OWN FILM
AND HE DOES, FEATURES INTERVIEWS
WITH BONO, SUSAN RICE,
BILL GATES AND SOME OF THE REST
OF THE WORST PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
BUT THE BEST PART OF THE
DOCUMENTARY COMES FROM
TONY FAUCI HIMSELF WHO IS NOT
SURPRISINGLY THE WORLD'S
GREATEST FAN OF TONY FAUCI.
HERE FOR EXAMPLES TONY FAUCI
EXPLAIN WHY SO MANY AMERICANS
DON'T TRUST HIM.
>> I AM THE BAD GUY TO AN ENTIRE
SUBSET OF PEOPLE BECAUSE I
REPRESENT SOMETHING THAT IS
UNCOMFORTABLE FOR THEM.
IT IS CALLED THE TRUTH.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
THEY CAN'T HANDLE THE TRUTH!
THOSE AMERICANS!
KEEP IN MIND SOME PEOPLE MAY
DISTRUST TONY FASCIA FOR OTHER
REASONS LIKE HE IS A LIAR AND HE
HAS ADMITTED IT.
HE LIED ABOUT SCIENTIFIC DATA
FOR EXAMPLE, ABOUT HERD IMMUNITY
AND HE HAS ADMITTED IT.
BUT IN THE DOCUMENTARY,
TONY FAUCI TAKING THE LONG VIEW
AND BEGGING HISTORIANS TO FORGET
ABOUT ALL OF IT.
>> I HOPE IF HISTORIANS LOOK
BACK, IF THEY EVER WOULD WANT TO
LOOK BACK AT WHAT I HAVE DONE
AND MY LIFE, MAYBE SOMEBODY
SAYS, HEY, THAT GUY WAS PRETTY
GOOD.
>> Tucker: THERE IS A
VACCINATED MAN WEARING A MASK
ALONE OUTSIDE, THAT IS CLEARLY A
SIGN OF MENTAL ILLNESS, BUT THE
FILM MAKES IT SEEM LIKE HEROISM.
WHAT DO WE MAKE OF THIS?
JESSE WATTERS IS AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK "HOW I SAVED THE WORLD,"
WHICH HE BASICALLY DID.
JESSE WATTERS, HAVE YOU SEEN
THIS?
>> NO, AND I DON'T PLAN ON IT.
BUT HE REALLY IS THE PERFECT
HOLLYWOOD ACTORS.
IT CRAVES ATTENTION, LOVES DRAMA
AND IF YOU CRITICIZE HIS
PERFORMANCE, THE ONLY HATE ME
BECAUSE I'M BEAUTIFUL.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
>> THIS IS THE THING, WE DON'T
HATE THE TRUTH WE JUST WANT TONY
TO TELL IT.
WE TRUST THE SCIENCE, WE JUST
DON'T TRUST THAT SCIENTIST,
BECAUSE, TUCKER, THIS IS THE
SAME GUY THAT FUNDED THE RISKY
RESEARCH IN THAT SLOPPY LAB THAT
SPRUNG THIS PANDEMIC, AND THEN
HE KEPT US ALL LOCKED INSIDE TO
PROTECT US FROM A VIRUS THAT
MOSTLY SPREADS INSIDE.
SO INSTEAD OF RESIGNING AND
DOING THE RIGHT THING, HE GOES
ON TELEVISION AND ACTUALLY
SUGGESTS THAT FUTURE HISTORIANS
DOCUMENT HIS LIFE AND TREAT HIM
AS A HERO.
NOW, AS SOMEONE WITH A HEALTHY
EGO, TUCKER, EVEN I BLUSH AT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
BUT MAYBE THIS IS JUST SATIRE.
THEY DO USE SUSAN RICE AS A
CHARACTER, THE BENGHAZI BAG LADY
OR MAYBE THIS IS DISNEY PAYING
FAUCI BACK BECAUSE DISNEY SHARES
WENT UP 100% DURING THE FAUCI
LOCKDOWNS.
EVERYONE STAYED HOME AND WATCHED
DISNEY PLUS AND THEY GOT ALL THE
BEIJING PROFITS COMING IN, SO
MAYBE IT IS JUST PAYBACK.
>> Tucker: BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
FILMMAKERS?
IF YOU'RE INTERVIEWING THE GUY
WHO HELPS CREATE COVID-19, LIED
ABOUT IT, GOT CAUGHT, FUNDED THE
FRANKENSTEIN EXPERIMENTS,
WOULDN'T YOU FEEL OBLIGATED TO
ASK HIM ABOUT IT?
>> IT'S TOO LATE BECAUSE NOW THE
MEDIA HAS ANOINTED HIM.
HE IS LORD LOCKED DOWN,
ARCHENEMY OF DONALD TRUMP,
SAVIOR OF EVERYTHING SCIENTIFIC
AND HOLY.
THE MEDIA WERE EARLY INVESTORS
IN THE FAUCI NARRATIVE.
THEY RODE THE FAUCI WAVE ALL THE
WAY TO POWER IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
BIG TECH AND BIG PHARMA ARE IN
ON THIS TOO APPEARED THEY CAN'T
PUMP AND DUMP, THERE'S TOO MUCHI